- Ici, on a plusieurs rangs
de maraîcher. On n'est pas
certifiés bio, mais je fais
tout comme.
- Katie Guillemette a acheté
cette petite ferme il y a deux
ans. Elle élève entre autres
300 poulets de grains par année,
qu'elle doit envoyer dans
un abattoir industriel.
KATIE GUILLEMETTE, coprop,
ferme Versant Shefford
- Ça te prend souvent une
quantité minimum. On les amène
tous, ils nous mettent ça sur
un crochet, c'est super
standardisé. Puis on revient
les chercher le lendemain.
C'est un petit peu dommage,
quand même, que moi qui est
artisan fermier, je n'ai pas
la possibilité d'être impliquée
dans le processus.
- Elle aimerait beaucoup
diversifier sa production,
ce qui est un peu compliqué
pour le moment.
- Aussitôt qu'on parle d'oiseaux
un peu plus rares comme
la pintade, même le canard
à la limite, c'est rendu de plus
en plus difficile à trouver des
endroits pour le faire faire.
On veut se réapproprier un petit
peu notre terroir, mais il n'y a
pas d'abattoir.
- Mais les choses sont en train
de changer.
- Enfin, là, c'est concret et
on peut vous faire visiter notre
infrastructure.
- La productrice d'oies Fernande
Ouellet, travaille depuis plus
de trois ans à développer
le Petit Abattoir.
FERNANDE OUELLET, chargée
de projets, Coopérative de
solidarité Le Petit Abattoir
- Alors ici, on est dans l'aire
d'arrivée du vivant. À cet
abattoir-ci, si on recevra
tout type de volailles
et des lapins.
- La coopérative a reçu sa
certification cette semaine.
Et elle va commencer ses
activités en août, avec
une dizaine de travailleurs.
- À la fin du cycle d'échaudage,
on prend les oiseaux, on les
envoie vers la plumeuse.
- À sa vitesse de croisière,
l'installation devrait traiter
environ 800 poulets par jour,
ou un peu moins s'il s'agit
d'oies ou de canards.
- D'adapter notre rythme
de travail pis notre hauteur de
travail aussi très facilement,
juste en faisant ça.
De l'adapter soit à l'espèce,
à l'âge des oiseaux, ou aux
différentes grosseurs qu'on peut
rencontrer suivant les conduites
d'élevage.
- L'achat et l'aménagement
des cinq conteneurs a coûté plus
de 850 000 dollars, dont
la moitié en subventions
gouvernementales.
- Lui-même ancien producteur,
le maire a soutenu le projet
dès le départ.
RENÉ BEAUREGARD, maire de Saint-
Joachim-de-Shefford
- Faut pas penser que ça peut
être fait juste ailleurs. On a
accepté de le faire chez nous
avec les contraintes qu'on a
quand même exigées au niveau
de la senteur, au niveau de
certains paramètres, mais tout
le temps dans l'idée qu'il
fallait que cette entité-là
existe à quelque part.
- C'est l'ingéniosité qui permet
d'obtenir le résultat.
- Ce qu'on a bâti, c'est pas
un abattoir. C'est un outil
de développement rural. Le pari
qu'on fait, c'est que si on le
bâtit, autour, l'agriculture va
se développer et l'agriculture
de subsistance aussi. Donc,
c'est la marche vers l'autonomie
alimentaire par le biais
des infrastructures.
- Elle rêve déjà que le modèle
soit repris dans de nombreuses
régions.
ANDRÉ LAMONTAGNE, ministre
de l'Agriculture du Québec
- D'abord, ce qui est important,
c'est que ce projet-là
réussisse. Mais après ça, pour
la possibilité d'avoir un autre
ou quelques autres projets
similaires sur le territoire
du Québec, ça prend une masse
critique de clientèle,
de produits à transformer.
C'est ça qui peut être complexe.
- On regarde peut-être pour
faire une table champêtre
éventuellement.
- Katie Guillemette, elle,
planifie la diversification
de son élevage.
- Ça change vraiment tout.
Si c'était pas du Petit
Abattoir, mon plan d'affaires,
change complètement. Je ne peux
plus miser sur tout ça, donc il
faudrait que je fasse quelque
chose de différent.
- Il reste à espérer que
la grippe aviaire, qui prend
de plus en plus d'ampleur au
Québec, ne viendra pas trop
bouleverser les plans
de la coopérative d'abattage.
Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-Canada,
St-Joachim-de-She